[Music]
in happy wife happy life news happy
girlfriend happy life mm-hmm but if you
don't learn fast recently no it's true
so many by its book and raw Gordon
Ramsay there's like screaming at
everyone else [ __ ] full control you
know the guy who has ten million cells
on you to believe that ten million subs
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome did you
Ramsey's or what Hell's Kitchen in Vegas
that's stuff Lisa I want a ham bar you
like trash food though we know what did
you get your flagship item I got a
burger exactly that's why cuz I know Joe
we go to a place that we're known for
pizza like we can't the oysters cute
couple has been coordinating their
outfits for nearly 70 about this and I
feel like he's like what stuff get out
guys oh yeah get out so his girl like
woman or grandmas like his woman or
grandma like soon they're like what
think it's we've been married for 68
years Francis and rosemary have how old
are they like [ __ ] a hundred I know to
be named herb Francis and rosemary
rosemary meet my wife time heaven time
lemon time oh yes we met in junior high
in Washington
oh and so they've been wearing the st.
like matching clothes since they were 19
years old and yeah they don't tell me
their age so I don't know they sounded
really old well since my gotta be so 19
19 years old plus 68 I mean they met and
yeah but didn't get married until maybe
like 18 or 16 if it's like mr.
coordinate maybe 16 you're right so
they're like junior high sweethearts no
I think by 19 they were still just
dating I mean they got to be at least 80
or 90 like in 90s then right yeah they
could have gotten married I got 19 they
people have married really young I heard
about this story on K Roth through Kevin
and bean I [ __ ] love Kevin to me uh
and then they they open it up with them
to kind of like singing acapella I was
oh you have it okay I wasn't sure if you
had it so yeah it sounds kind of creepy
but it's cute but it's creepy cuz they
have an acapella group with just the two
of them when she came into our town by
the time we were seniors we start going
together Francis knows the jerem happy
wife happy life all - Wow beetles
letting his ride at more than a half a
century
well we mail into your everyday without
for me and I don't have to worry about a
thing Jesus first other second yourself
last that's a way to spell joy Jesus and
others and you what a wonderful way to
spell joy they look like something like
a couple that would work at Disneyland
like yeah the view yes they are cute
my grandfather has a certain word please
beat starts with that Oh and ends with T
that are their double letters in the
middle there's a couple letters in the
middle of us and there's a more photo
their matching outfit gets even better I
mean yeah give more news after that what
else so then they that's not well it's
measuring so they have kids right and
now their kids up get so their
grandchildren are gonna start a clothing
line with matching that for your match
like matching couple would yeah didn't
read that that's cute yeah your growl is
ease down for that my drunk grandfather
first of all cuz I never saw him sober
but I would imagine if he was there's no
way you could get him liquor
enough to ever wear the same thing my
grandma's wearing even color-coordinated
to anything they probably had a really
loving relationship though right they
did they actually did but he there's no
way in hell you could get him into a
right outfits in one of my grandma was a
shared hobby or shared interest that
your grandparents had watching
television yeah
making she makes him food and then like
glaze at the front of oh yes sir oh
there we go
came home mixed two liquors that's how
we drank he was this like he had like a
spritzer he had a full bar he needed
like two pumps bourbon oh we got a pump
a Bruin that's what you know that this
is this is this is like alcohol this is
what do you have a plug a dedicated like
unit filling really good clear liquid
was either tequila or vodka yeah that
guy was a badass dude [ __ ] oh yeah
he wouldn't talk to you about [ __ ] [ __ ]
he wouldn't tell you his voice you want
to tell you that his friend I don't need
to do no [ __ ] [ __ ] he doesn't need to
talk about his problems you don't have
trauma yeah when they went into because
he had he died of stage liver failure
he called his liver a [ __ ] yeah bright
when he went in they found that he had
three broken ribs three days prior the
guy went to Costco and he comes back
with like huge [ __ ] trays or like
Mountain Dew and [ __ ] huh that's true
cuz talking about talking about pain was
[ __ ] [ __ ] back then [ __ ] no so they
were broken but like dudes it whether
you like trying to be fused together
something because your body will
naturally trying to heal that you good
question I they just said that you have
three broken limbs do you know that and
he's like I don't know wow you know what
your voice sounds like the guy that the
the old guy that his penis started
turning into bone and they told him that
his penis is hasta flying and he was
just like I look the older generation
was gangster dude those guys are badass
that's what I'm saying he would see
there shouldn't be like God Jesus just
[ __ ] kill me already I went to war
for these [ __ ] Yeah right
so these [ __ ] can survive using
freedom at what cost at least the
Communists had something to go for it is
like Stalin was on to something yeah
we're a [ __ ] furry hat big deal you
don't gotta wear a blouse with your wife
[Laughter]
like grandpa talk I like that they
harmonize though it is cute
they've been saying like they were old
like old style they're called singing
chaplains and they perform at their
local church hospitals and even just
around their house I'm not surprised
who do you think this this whole idea is
do you think that you take a guess you
take the stab at it from the music from
everything because I get the outfits cuz
he said he lays out the clothes I can
tell you I began and there's how it's
been all along
so she said rosemary a controlling [ __ ]
she seems like they were in high school
rosemary picked out matching shirts and
her mom bought it for them and since
then they've been matching and she's
been picking out every outfit for him
he's like yeah what do you think about
anything and I'm like you're onto
something there that is true that's a
Steve Jobs level kind of thinking right
there yeah close for me all the time I
work yeah same here
my wife picks up my clothes and now
she's like man I should have picked up
more than like three outfits but I'm
like no and you're wearing those [ __ ]
into the ground yes sir yes sir you
dress me I will really chill out my why
is it a No
why is what enough cuz he said no if she
said more than three outfits
oh well no she's like you know I wish I
had more variety but I'm like no I'm
good with this this is like good about
for me because anymore it would be too
much just want to keep track of what is
your closet look like it's like three
shirt three three pan sorry what's
Nicky's closet looks like my closets
actually filled with [ __ ] but I need to
get rid of a lot of it like what kind of
[ __ ]
oh just well I mean clothes first but
then I also have like a bunch of wire
boxes and things that well here's
video because my wife doesn't have to
pay China we can shield never see this
if it something yeah yeah so here's
something that I will never admit to my
wife in the shoes here my wire box is
basically it's like a [ __ ] it's like
my flag okay I don't really need all the
[ __ ] in the wire box but for me I got a
hold on to it because it's the principle
of the goddamn thing she's been trying
to get rid of this wire box since we've
been together
yes so but it's yours that's right for
my [ __ ] wire box and I need it
because I said I can you know it away
when you want to throw it away when I
decide it's not useful inside of it any
wires that are really tangled show you
can't find [ __ ] it's a mess in there
yeah it's hard to find anything yeah you
probably hate looking at it but you're
like mine goddamn it I have unspecial
things but then when just tells me to
throw it away it becomes special Tony
yeah thank you
that's right but it's like no this is a
family [ __ ] heirloom yeah Joey go
man's like I would have thrown it away
forever
then I'll throw it away but as a
catapult you can't decide what is
special to me I decide what is special
to but this is the only thing then this
is all I got left
TV television you have sentimental [ __ ]
do you
Casey told me that earlier he's like you
don't care about anything and I'm like
what is how do I get how do I get this
Brandon you're not a collector you don't
have hobbies like you don't have a thing
you know like yeah but that's that
doesn't take up space but if you had a
basketball collection and yet so many
[ __ ] balls everyone do you care about
that care about my wife care about you
guys of course oh but I guess I'm not
people category since we know that now
yeah you liquor
Bitcoin action have anything yeah
writing just writing stuff that seashell
collection or snap or any baseball cards
I have like a look above this many comic
books hmm okay that's it
collect everything not really flex parts
I got a lot shouldn't even throw away
listen I think about it and I don't want
to throw it away
yeah see exactly like everything in his
office things could be thrown away yeah
but don't you [ __ ] think about it
mother I do it when you're not looking
can we get rid of these couches these
are the most uncomfortable couches on
that you know it's really we can't get
rid of them cause every time I look at
that couch I think Isaac used to eat
back that's the memory
oh yeah it's like are you eating the
couch it's like seaweed all these black
spots on space oh it doesn't remember is
that yeah I don't bring it up
that's embarrassing you know he's going
to school now he could he could they
could make fun of him for that you hate
you the couch heater boy everybody but
you put yourself or drugs later so
that's that kid can do not mean y'all
are weird
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]